foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
our good buddy Matt Miller he's covering
the draft for the mothership and he
writes for espn.com contributes to
multiple shows like get up and NFL live
we thought we should have Matt on see
that whatever happened at the combine
how does that affect the draft if any
Matt joins us now on the program uh so
did you see anything that's really going
to shake up the draft order here Matt
yeah Dan I think anytime you have a
quarterback who is six foot four to 44
pounds runs to four four three and then
lights up the throwing workout like
Florida's Anthony Richardson did that's
it's gonna shake things up whether
people want to say the combines
overrated or underwear Olympics don't
matter they do when you with Anthony
Richardson we knew he was athletic we
knew he had a big arm we knew he was
working on improving things like his
footwork that was going to make his
accuracy better but I think when you go
to the combine and you test as the most
athletic quarterback in combine history
that matters and I do think if you look
now at Bryce Young's five ten and an
eight and he's he's the size of a high
schooler now he's really good but when
you stand Bryce young next to Anthony
Richardson and you say which guy am I
going to bet my franchise on I do think
it is hard to look at them standing side
by side and say hey Bryce young is our
guy and I I love Bryce young he's my top
quarterback in his draft but as at a
certain point Size Matters and even I
would throw Ohio State CJ Stroud in
there to be sticks three 215 standing
next to a 5 10 and an eight hundred four
pound Bryce young is a completely
different world so I think you know the
combine definitely helps put things like
that in context for all right for me for
people that do a job like mine and also
for NFL teams all right then give me the
downside to Anthony Richardson
a 54 completion percentage it's it's
there and I think you know even that
number requires some some deeper Dives
you know how many were dropped how many
were throwaways how many were you know
just bad passes from him and there are
quite a few and so I think the list of
first round quarterbacks under 55 in
their careers like Jake Locker Ryan Leaf
and Kyle bowler it's not good it's not a
good list of quarterbacks sub 55 in the
first round so it's diving into that
context of Josh Allen was not accurate
Wyoming because his footwork was all
over the place and the guys he was
throwing to were not very good and so I
think with Richardson now we're all
going back myself NFL teams we're going
back of okay he only started 13 games in
college he threw fewer than 400 passes
how much of that accuracy is fixable how
much of it's not fixable I thought he
looked a lot better at the combine you
know with a stronger foundation in his
throwing to where his feet weren't all
over the place and that's what Josh
Allen did he went from Wyoming to the
Senior Bowl and looked markedly better
from the cedarborough the combine he
almost looks like a different
quarterback combiner pro day he proved
that it was locked in that the changes
he had made weren't just for one
afternoon in Indianapolis that they were
actually a change that he made to his
game Richardson has to do the same thing
all it takes is one team to fall in love
what's uh give me the team
that's going to fall in love with
Anthony Richardson
I I mean the Indianapolis Colts I think
with the with the structure they have
you've got coaches coming from
Indianapolis where you had a ton of
success with a quarterback that can beat
you with his legs he could beat you with
his arm and I think you're you're
standing there looking at that player
there's no one like this in our division
a division that is wide open right now
unless you you know believe
Jacksonville's got something going that
they can sustain so I think Indianapolis
is a team that makes a lot of sense at
the number four pick would you rather
have Anthony Richardson in all your
draft picks or trade up for Bryce young
and not have a first-time draft pick
next year and I think that becomes an
interesting conversation for all these
teams is the difference between Bryce
young and Anthony Richardson or CJ
Stroud and anything Richardson is it
worth three draft picks and I'm not so
sure that it is I think you might be in
a better spot to draft a quarterback at
four and not have to trade up and get
crazy because you still need a left
tackle you still need another wide
receiver so I think we had a lot of bad
teams at the top of this draft that are
not in a situation to be giving away
their future draft Capital yeah I had uh
NFL scout tell me that the draft
comparison since we always love to do
that for Anthony Richardson was Dante
Culpepper
yeah athletically that's a good one it
absolutely is I think people have to
remember what Culpepper was coming out
of college too we're not talking about
late career when he couldn't move
anymore yeah but that early career I
heard Steve McNair comparisons as well
okay you know of someone who just
beautiful deep ball great athletic
ability it's gonna get fun it's gonna be
a fun eight weeks I I'm curious about CJ
Stroud he's sort of the Forgotten guy
and if you want to talk an unbelievable
performance at the end of the year
against Georgia
and it's almost as if you know we keep
saying about Ohio State quarterbacks I
don't know how good they are you go back
you know with fields and Haskins you
know down through the list here is CJ
Stroud different and why is he being
overlooked when it comes to we talked
about Bryce young we talked about will
miss Anthony Richardson we talked about
you know Stetson Bennett more than than
CJ strong what what are we missing here
we're missing a lot I honor I think he's
the second best quarterback in this
draft and he really might be one B to
Bryce Young's 1A I mean like I said the
size is there his best game as you
mentioned Dan was against Georgia a
historically great defense and he he
showed all the things that when you said
he couldn't do you know the knock on him
at Ohio State for two years was not only
does he not run I mean there are times
he just flat out would not run it looks
like it was something he did not even
care to try to do but then you played
Georgia which is a great defense and he
he's running he's rolling out he's
scrambling he's making all these plays
with his legs and his arm so I think he
showed a part of his game that was there
but just not being used the same thing
happened to Justin Herbert coming out of
Oregon people compared him to Joe burrow
and Tua and said he doesn't he doesn't
run he doesn't use his legs and then you
find out that the Oregon staff didn't
want him to run and use his legs because
he was too valuable they didn't want him
taking you know hits that he didn't have
to it makes me think CJ Stroud's gonna
be a similar situation where once he's
in the NFL we're gonna he's gonna get
opened up and do more things so everyone
does everybody wants to scout the helmet
and say Ohio State quarterbacks you know
Michigan didn't have a great run of
quarterbacks before Tom Brady LSU didn't
have a great run at quarterbacks before
Joe burrow Texas Tech no that's Patrick
Mahomes there's Cliff Kingsbury wasn't
great in the NFL there's always going to
be that the person that breaks you know
the cycle and I I do think CJ Stroud has
yes the armed Talent we've seen now the
mobility he definitely has the football
IQ he he throws the best ball of any of
these quarterbacks in his workout
Saturday night in Indianapolis was one
of the better throwing workouts I've
ever seen at the combine I mean it was
it was a show as much as Anthony
Richardson's you know vertical jump at
40 were a show CJ Stroud's actual
throwing of the football was I I think
just impressive
what are the Bears going to do up top
and they're telling everybody oh listen
they'll trade they probably trade you
guys the pick right now if you called
and offered enough so uh all for princy
to the Bears they might they might trade
it I mean they they want to I mean they
I I thought it was really interesting
that I woke up Monday morning and Peter
King had a piece on the Bears trading
and Albert Brewer had a piece on the
Bears trading everybody talked to Ryan
Post in Indianapolis and he told
everyone the same thing they really want
to trade that pick so whether it's how
far back I think is the question this is
not a great top end of the draft
especially now with the Jalen Carter
situation and all the unknowns that come
into play there if you're Chicago you
can't go back very far because Will
Anderson I think has to be your target
the pass rusher out of Alabama they had
the fewest acts of any team in the NFL
last year they have to get someone who
can disrupt the quarterback and
especially in a year where there's not a
left tackle who will be a top five pick
there's not a wide receiver who will be
a top five pick you really can't get out
of that range of Will Anderson so I mean
do you do you trade back to two three
with Arizona I mean it's going to be I
wouldn't want to get past Arizona
because it feels like they would take
Will Anderson if he's there always great
to talk to you Matt congrats on the
success and we'll check in with you as
we lead up to the draft
all right thanks guys that's uh Matt
Miller ESPN draft analyst and uh he
writes for espn.com contributes to
multiple shows including getup and NFL
Live